ich vermute unterstelle mal viele von
ihnen zu hause haben das gar nicht
mitbekommen aber in diesen tagen beginnt
der abzug der nato-truppen aus
afghanistan
20 jahre haben unsere soldaten und
soldatinnen da ihr leben riskiert leider
weitgehend ignoriert von der deutschen
öffentlichkeit jetzt heißt es alles muss
raus möglichst schon bis zum vierten
juli ja die usa haben den deutschen
trotz abgeschickt by the way wir ziehen
doch schon früher ab an eurer stelle
würde ich auch packen
es wirkt irgendwie fluchtartig und den
armen afghanen drohen jetzt genau zwei
szenarien entweder ist nach dem abzug
wieder bürgerkrieg oder die taliban
übernehmen den laden direkt was macht da
noch hoffnung mit blick auf die zukunft
setzen wir darauf dass die taliban
verstanden haben dass die konflikte in
afghanistan politisch gelöst werden
müssen
ja ich denke diese klaren worte geben
den taliban sehr zu denken
kurz zur realität in 28 von 34
afghanischen provinzen wird längst
wieder gekämpft
ja die haben wahrscheinlich das memo vom
heiko noch nicht gekriegt keine frage
man könnte wahrscheinlich noch 20 jahre
da bleiben ohne diese steinzeit armee zu
besiegen der eigentliche fehler war
damals ohne echten plan reinzugehen
was sagen denn die taliban ich sage mal
so er hier will er nicht über die
landesliste ins parlament einziehen
nun kündigt wenn die afghanische
regierung die scharia anerkennt werden
wir keine probleme haben
die lösung mit den amerikanern ist dass
die regierung sich nicht bei uns
einmischt und wir nicht bei ihnen
wir haben den amerikanern die
möglichkeit gegeben dass sie in frieden
abziehen können na das klingt doch fair
und viel versprechen also außer für die
afghanische bevölkerung die ein paar
jahre lang hoffnung schnuppern durfte es
gehen zum beispiel immer mehr mädchen
zur schule
die frage ist nur wie lange noch gerade
diese woche haben die taliban einen
kompletten bezirk nur wenige kilometer
vor der hauptstadt kabul erobert jeden
tag gibt es neue anschläge und besonders
gefährlich wird es natürlich für die
afghanen die für uns arbeiten zum
beispiel als dolmetscher der bundeswehr
ich nehme mal an
ich gehe mal davon aus die lassen wir da
nicht einfach zurück oder die bundeswehr
hat angekündigt bedrohten afghanischen
orts kräften helfen zu wollen
dafür sollen in masar und tier in kabul
kontaktbüro eröffnet werden in denen
sich bedrohte ortskräfte wie mohammed
melden können
ja was ihre praktisch ist weil dann
können sich die taliban mit einem
campingstuhl force kontaktbüro setzen
und warten bis unsere ortskräfte
rauskommen das kann doch wohl nicht wahr
sein können wenn ich wegen ist diese
menschen einfach mal ganz bald
unbürokratisch in flugzeuge setzten
doch zurzeit ist es so die wiederholten
ortskräfte müssen ihre gefährdung
nachweisen
dann können sie visa beantragen und
müssten schließlich die flugtickets aus
eigener tasche bezahlen
das ist bitte nicht euer ernst absolut
beschämend für uns alle meine klar für
den sehr übereilten abzug kann die
bundeswehr natürlich nix das geht vor
allem auf kosten der amis aber für
unsere ortskräfte sind wir schon selber
verantwortlich sonst hängt da am 5 juli
in kundus seien zettel am kasernentor da
steht drauf leute wir mussten spontan
nach hause abschiede sind nicht so unser
ding danke für alles im kühlschrank
steht noch ein halber kasten paderborner
ach ihr trinkt ja nicht schön eure
bundeswehr
ps wir können ja masken der abzug
wahrscheinlich die gefährlichste phase
der gesamten afghanistan-mission und
dieser abzug wird gesichert
von unserer elite einheit ksk dem
kommando spezialkräfte sie wissen das
sind diese sehr breit gebauten und sehr
gut ausgebildeten vollprofis die meist
nicht den schlüsseldienst rufen um die
tür auf zu kriegen ja allerdings ist es
auch genau dieses ksk das aa kk gerade
kopfschmerzen macht wegen denen wackelt
vielleicht sogar ihr job beim ksk sind
munition und sprengstoff verschwunden
und dann hat der chef der kommandeur von
denen gesagt leute ich stelle hier im
karton hin und wieder morgen alles
wieder drin liegt ist die sache für mich
erledigt
jetzt wird gegen ihn ermittelt wegen
strafvereitlung im amt
dabei war die aktion super erfolgreich
im rahmen einer umstrittenen amnestie
aktion bei der eliteeinheit kommando
spezialkräfte
in calw haben soldaten mehr
unterschlagene munition zurückgegeben
als vermisst worden war
die wundersame munitions vermehrung war
wahrscheinlich ein zählfehler denn es
fehlen immer noch 13.000 schuss ganz
wichtig die große mehrheit dieser truppe
steht natürlich auf dem boden der
verfassung und macht einen super
wichtigen super gefährlichen job den
wackelige zivi gestalten wie ich niemals
machen könnten
allerdings sieht der militärische
abschirmdienst mrd rund 50 rechtsextreme
verdachtsfälle nur beim ksk ja 50 das
ist viel ein ksk mann ist gerade erst zu
zwei jahren auf bewährung verurteilt
worden nachdem man in seinem garten
massenhaft vergrabene munition und in
seinem haus nazi devotionalien gefunden
hat ein weiterer kreis kader gehörte zu
den köpfen des hannibal netzwerkes das
in deutschland einen rechten umsturz
geplant hat und dann war da ja noch
diese legendäre party bei der ksk
soldaten rechtsrock gehört und wohl den
hitlergruß gezeigt haben oder es sei
kein hitlergruß gewesen vielmehr habe
man sich mit cäsar gästen begrüßt
stimmt da war ja auch nazi vergisst man
immer tatsächlich wurden bei dieser fete
im wald auch noch schweine köpfe
geworfen warum auch immer man muss wohl
dabei gewesen sein
ein ksk hauptmann hat schon vor einem
jahr in einem regelrechten brandbrief an
die verteidigungsministerin geschrieben
rechtsextreme tendenzen würden bei denen
geduldet oder sogar wissentlich
vertuscht was macht man da jetzt
vielleicht zeichnet sich da ein neuer
job für unsere afghanistan truppe so
leute das war's in afghanistan
wir haben das land gemeinsam und sagen
wie aus spaß mal
demokratisiert glückwunsch und hier
kommt eure neue mission als nächstes
demokratisieren wir calw in baden
württemberg dort hat sich eine in teilen
gefährliche parallelgesellschaft namens
ksk eingenistet einige von denen lehman
unsere verfassung ab sind bewaffnet und
leider sehr gut ausgebildet übrigens von
uns andere geschichte und vorsicht bei
denen sind sogar die männer verschleiert
in diesem sinne viel glück leute ihr
macht das lohnen
ja ich fürchte gegen das ksk hat die
bundeswehr keine chance tatsächlich ist
aber auch schon was passiert eine ganze
kompanien calw wurde aufgelöst und für
neues personal gibt es demnächst
verschärfte sicherheitsüberprüfung
immerhin ich finde es überhaupt wichtig
bei sowas auch mal die betroffenen zu
hören
hallo liebe mitbürger über uns sind
gerade ein paar blöde missverständnisse
umlauf ja 13 tausend schuss munition und
62 kilogramm sprengstoff die sind ja nie
verschwunden
nein dafür gibt es eine ganz einfache
erklärung wir nehmen uns die arbeit mit
nach hause ja humor fit macht doch jeder
frosch mit krone halt für home office
nimmt man natürlich sagen
arbeitsmaterial mit nach hause
schatz haben wir irgendwo joha mich
schon
und hopp
[Musik]
aha genauso wie die normalos habe selbst
ich als elitesoldat im osten paar kilo
drogen park bleibt er nicht aus aber
dafür habe ich mit den taliban auch nur
person konferenz zu tun
danke schadlos freunde alten siegen
lernen wäre hätte ich mich eure mikrofon
ausscheidet und hbm eshop um
professionell für fachkräfte wie uns
sind waffen zu hause nicht das problem
sondern die lösung zum beispiel bäume
fällen
clown sprengstoff ist tatsächlich das
hausmittel gegen abgelaufen
sie sehen das ist alles halb so wild
auch diese blöde sache da mit ein paar
echt
daher ist eine richtig gute idee
klar werden die weiter zu uns kommen
weil die waffen und uniformen geil
finden
deshalb suchen wir jetzt für jeden neuen
rechten rekruten ganz gezielt ein
linksextrem als ausgleich gestellt in
dem brennenden straßen von leipzig
connewitz willkommen bei der ksk männer
tot dem kapitalistischen schweizer
system jetzt im durchschnitt
demokratisch
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]